house republicans are finally making
moves to oust
liz chaney from her position of
leadership my only question isn't
why it's what took them so long on the
surface the move to bounce chaney
appears to be about her criticism of
donald trump
but on a deeper level this is about
removing the final vestiges of
neoconservatism
from the gop as a recovering neocon
myself
this is healthy and welcome it also
affirms that when it comes to the border
culture patriotism a strong military
exposing the fake news media and much
more
trumpism americanism is here to stay
but the democrats see it a bit
differently this is what joe biden said
about the push
earlier today it seems as though the
republican party
is trying to identify what it stands for
and they're in the midst of a
significant uh sort of mini-revolution
going on the republican party oh boy
whispering
there's no identity crisis in the party
there's no revolution
this rumored move proves that the gop is
as much today as on election day
the party of trump just as reagan
defined the gop for 25 years trump will
do the same
and that's a good thing liz cheney
sensing that her time is up
made the case to keep her job today in
the favorite newspaper of every died in
the wool conservative
the washington post joining me now
former speaker of the house newt
gingrich
and representative jim jordan mr speaker
uh is
is this a party in revolution you led
one
or do they know who their leader is and
it's time to change
liz cheney out
well those are two different questions i
think this is a party
which has broadly become a deeply
pro-american party
a deeply committed uh anti-counter
culture party
a party that believes washington has to
be taken on
and washington has to be changed i think
all that's true
part of it relates to trump but candidly
part of it's bigger than trump you may
not want to hear that but it's true
this is a long-term national movement
that goes all the way back to goldwater
and has continued to build momentum on
on liz's part look the chaneys are a
very smart
very experienced family they have a
remarkable record of serving
i thought she had every right as an
individual member
to vote her conscience she had no right
to use the chairmanship of the
conference
to exploit her position when in fact the
conference by
about 200 to 10. that's 20 to 1
was on the other side and that's why i
think
from an internal legislative standpoint
she simply can't be chairman
of a conference that she refuses to
listen to i mean
this is this business is about listening
not just about speaking
and she clearly refuses to listen
representative jordan you're in the
middle of it you're in the conference
uh do you do you believe she needs to go
and if so
who should who should replace her yes
you definitely need to go and the
speaker's right we are a pro america
populist party rooted in conservative
principle with donald trump as our
leader that he has brought so many new
people to this party
and that is a darn good thing you can't
have a republican conference chair
reciting democrat talking points you
can't have a republican conference chair
taking a position that 90 percent of the
party disagrees with
and you can't have a republican party
chair consistently speaking out against
the individual who 74 million americans
voted for
so that that is the problem i was for
making a change three months ago
and the speaker's also right look if liz
stays in congress that's between her and
the voters in her district and her great
state of wyoming
but you can't be the conference chair
when you consistently speak out against
the leader of our party
and you consistently speak out against
the positions that the vast vast vast
majority of our party and our country i
think
holds representative just real quick
follow-up in the open i
mentioned why so long you mentioned you
were calling for it three months ago why
does something like this that seems
evident for a while takes so long to
come to manifestation
well because once once she was uh three
months ago when the decision was made
she continued to do what what speaker
gingrich talked about she continued to
speak for herself and not for the
conference
not for the republican party and this
has been a pattern that goes clear back
to last fall
in the run-up to the election she was
against the president on his afghanistan
paula his
uh serious policy she spoke she spoke
against him on the on the russian bounty
issue which we all know was a was a
complete hoax
so it's a consistent pattern and finally
it just became so
much and for so long that our conference
says
we've got to make a change and i believe
that's going to happen very soon
mr speaker you said something about and
i think it's so true that the republican
party has become
counter-cultural in a sense uh you know
rejecting the old institutions of
washington
like the washington post that folks like
the cheney's have been friendly with for
years
is that is that is that the complete
strain will they be able to say
we're going to run on the fact that we
reject washington in totality not just
sort of
not flirt with washington but we are
going to leave the type of revolution
you talked about
sure and look it's beyond washington
uh donald j trump just got a huge boost
from facebook which basically canceled
him
making him a martyr and helping convince
every single american that if you can
get 75 million votes
and some oligarch sitting there in his
palace in
california can cancel you
then they can they can cancel anybody in
america
that's a pretty good campaign choice you
want to be with the oligarchs like like
biden apparently is
or do you want to stand for freedom and
the right of every person
to be heard and so i think this stuff's
going to go on
and it is very profound
it does literally go back to barry
goldwater starting the late 50s
reagan picked it up to some extent we
did at the
contract with america now trump has
personified it
it ain't going away and it's a
profoundly different party
than the party of 20 or 30 years ago
absolutely exit question real quick
representative jordan do you have the
votes will it happen
yeah i think that for sure the votes are
there and i think it will happen
most likely next wednesday there you go
representative jim jordan speaker newt
gingrich
both of you really appreciate your time
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else